I'm in sixth grade so what's your advice
for me as a sixth grader who says six
more years of class and what are you
thinking um
like do you like it yes but I feel like
the stuff I love learning is stuff like
this yes and I'm not learning like stuff
that is in the real world so I think I
think you need to think about your next
six years as a vacation okay the way I
thought about school in sixth grade was
I just have to get through these six
years and let me enjoy it let me like
play with my friends and hang out and
spend time learning what I wanted to
learn for me that was baseball card
shows going to flea markets for you got
the whole [__] world the whole
[__] internet you kids [__] have
it so good if I [__] have what you
had [__] just enjoy it because you're
never gonna be a kid again and have so
much free time and she's gonna have
[__] experiences and expenses and
issues so instead of being upset about
it enjoy it because it's your last real
vacation all right foreign